what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
andrew garfield is finally talking about
his role returning as his spider-man in
spider-man no way home remember when he
said that he wasn't the werewolf when he
was very adamant
that he wasn't the werewolf and remember
when he said that the photo was
photoshopped on jimmy fallon well if you
show me the photo i can tell you whether
it's it's me or whether it's a real
thing it's been a race off the internet
oh how convenient detective fallon i
heard about it
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop
we say no
i'm trying to manage expectations you
say no well now here we are and
obviously we all know now that he is
actually in spider-man knowing home with
toby mcguire this is the first time that
he's actually opening up about being in
the film in an interview with right he
actually talks about a lot including
what it was like when he first got the
call from kevin feige and amy pascal
over at marvel and sony and they
actually talk about his future coming up
there have been a lot of rumors and
reports about whether or not he's going
to be returning a lot of reports about
him being in multiple projects maybe
both in the mcu and in the sony universe
so this article is going to shed a lot
of light on what that was like when
andrew first got the call what it was
like working on spider-man knowing home
with tobey maguire and tom holland and
if he is open to return for some future
projects so let's dive into it but first
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu sony spider-man universe and
spider-man news so the title of this
variety article is titled andrew
garfield finally spills about spider-man
return and future
we're gonna go down to the first
question that they ask him which is
starting simple why did you say yes to
no way home and here's what he said i
wasn't expecting to ever have a
conversation again about potentially
playing peter parker i felt very excited
to just be a fan again but i got this
call from amy pascal and kevin feige and
john watts with this idea it was
immediately undeniable it sounded
incredibly fun incredibly spiritual
trippy and thematically interesting
on a base level as a spider-man fan just
the idea of seeing three spider-men in
the same frame was enough this is pretty
cool because i think andrew because of
the hate that he got for the amazing
spider-man franchise which again is not
his fault i think he did a really good
job at playing spider-man it's not his
fault that the movies weren't
necessarily good but i think this is
really cool because he clearly put all
that behind him right i'm sure he went
through a lot but eventually did put all
that behind him and became a spider-man
fan because he said so many times he's a
huge spider-man fan a huge spider-man
fan so he finally got to a place it
sounds like where he's just sitting back
and enjoying everything and then he gets
this incredible call from amy pasquel
over at sony and kevin feige the
president of marvel studios and they ask
him
to come back as spider-man here's what
he continues to say
the pitch was really really enticing
they said you played this character in
your way and what would you want to
explore if you had an opportunity if you
were dumped into this other universe and
faced with this younger you and this
older you how will you respond and it's
really cool that on this call they
actually asked him right because it's
his spider-man how would you feel
if you were in this situation how would
your spider-man your peter parker react
if you saw an older one and a younger
one which was tom holland so that's
really cool that they asked for his
input but he goes on to say we talked a
lot about mentorship which is really
cool and i really love that about the
movie we talked a lot about brotherhood
and about what it is to be the older
brother younger brother and the middle
brother there's also a thing of seeing
someone you love walking down a path
that you've already walked down and you
know it doesn't lead to the place where
you ultimately meant to go we saw this
in the movie where he's telling tom
holland's peter parker i stopped holding
my punches i got bitter and he kind of
lost himself goes on to say that the
character is isolated in his emotional
experience and physical experience but
what happens when that aloneness gets
blasted open and you come to realize
that you've never been alone and there
are other brothers going through the
exact same thing that's a big spiritual
journey to go on man and then we just
melt out all the fun that we possibly
could have and i think they definitely
did and
it's very very interesting because i
think as far as the character is
concerned not him personally but the
character after losing gwen
seeing the other two like the whole i've
always wanted brother line that he says
in the movie is like really really cool
and i think for his character that was
like a really really huge moment for him
and i do hope we see more of his
character which we are going to talk
about because he talks about and it's
just so amazing that they came back and
in fact the next question says you and
toby maguire really did this this wasn't
a green screen set up in your driveway
and they have a profound impact on tom
holland spider-man andrew garfield said
we were shooting for two weeks toby and
die but i think we managed to achieve
something that is not just showing up
and going hi bye my spider-man got to
save his younger brother's romantic
relationship potentially and to heal the
most traumatic moment of his own life
through doing it for his younger brother
making sure that he didn't have the same
fate there's something cosmically
beautiful about that it meant getting a
second chance at saving gwen and that's
huge and that was i think to me the best
part of the film
i
i every time i watch the movie i have
cried at that part because i just andrew
he lands and he's crying because he's
like oh my gosh i did it right i
couldn't do it before i couldn't save my
gwen but i could save my younger
brothers gwen right his mj i did it
right i failed before but i did this
time it's a huge redeeming moment and as
we can see right here from what he said
it it's cosmic right it's a cosmically
beautiful thing that he's able to do
this and it's it's to me i think the
best part of the movie and they actually
go on to talk about the redemption one
of the questions says a lot of the
conversation about this movie has been
about a sort of redemption for your
spider-man narratively commercially how
does that feel and this is what andrew
said i'm so grateful i'm just really
really grateful that i got to tie up
some loose ends for the peter parker
that i was playing i love that character
and i'm grateful that i got to work with
these incredible actors this incredible
director and marvel in conjunction with
sony it was joyful and a feeling of
closure for me there were so many
unanswered questions for my peter where
we left it i got to step back in and get
some healing for him and also really
supporting tom holland's peter and
honoring his character completing that
trilogy not distracting or detracting
from it and i think that's actually
something they did incredibly well the
other spider-man came in but they didn't
really take away from tom holland's
story they added to it right they became
his uncle ben's in a type of way they
became his mentors his older brothers
they they added to everything they
didn't steal the spotlight they shared
it together for that moment and tom
still had his spotlight at the end and i
really really enjoyed it because i think
they did that perfectly and i think
that's what andrew is saying right here
but now for you know the big question
right here
would you be open
to coming back to the character
again a lot of rumors have been going
around about him returning and here's
what he says i mean yes
definitely open to something if it felt
right
peter and spider-man those characters
are all about service to the greater
good and the many
he's a working class boy from queens
that knows struggle and loss and is
deeply empathetic i would try to borrow
peter parker's ethical framework in that
if there was an opportunity to step back
in and tell more of that story i would
have to feel very sure and certain in
myself and i think
after spider-man knowing home he could
definitely feel sure and certain for
himself because they did it right i
think if they did a project with sony or
in the mcu they would definitely nail it
down for his character especially after
this big redeeming moment for him and
spider-man home i think there's a lot
more story to tell now more than before
actually because he's had that redeeming
moment so they can tell what he's gone
through before they can kind of give us
you know a tiny little flashback of him
in the way home and then tell his story
going on from here how he's redeemed
himself how he's not bitter anymore and
maybe toby can come back and maybe he
can see tom's peter parker as well who
knows i think there's a lot of potential
here a lot of potential here and it
looks like andrew garfield if given the
opportunity will come back and i think
based off of everything that we've heard
from some credible insiders they're
definitely talking about it right now
working on maybe that perfect fit for
him to come back as his spider-man and
hopefully that means the same thing for
toby i get it toby's a little bit older
but i'd still love to see him come back
maybe not get his own solo movie but
maybe if andrew gets another solo movie
toby could appear and we could get more
of the spider-man together again but
this is just awesome andrew was finally
talking about spider-man knowing home
after denying that he is the werewolf
after denying that he is in the film
obviously we get it he has to deny it
right we knew that he couldn't just come
out and say hey yeah no totally i'm in
the movie but i think him going you know
on these talk shows and stuff denying it
built up a lot of hype and i think it
was really really well done and i loved
him in knowing home i love toby let me
know what you guys think about this in
the comments down below though i'm
hoping that he returns and i'm hoping we
get uh the amazing spider-man 3 or he
jumps into another project along the
line that's what i'm hoping for fingers
crossed i know a lot of people want that
as well so be sure to subscribe and hit
the notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest spider-man news
specifically involving andrew garfield
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you